I told you about six or seven weeks ago
that there's a good chance that the DNC
changes the debate requirements in order
to allow the late Michael Bloomberg late
and sorry Michael Bloomberg is a lot is
allow alive I mean the late to the race
Michael Bloomberg and the quite frankly
rapidly surging Michael Bloomberg into
the debates and it's happening it's
happening exactly as I predicted and now
we will see what the other candidates
say the requirements to qualify for
debates have included a combination of
polling numbers and donor requirements
total number of donors and donors and I
think it's at least 20 states and then
polling in early states billionaire
Michael Bloomberg entered this race very
very late and just bought his way in he
hasn't been raising money from
individual donors he doesn't need to
he's a turbo billionaire he has a lot
more money than Donald Trump and he's
just been funding his own campaign which
means he wouldn't be able to qualify for
the debates because he's not accepting
individual donations that being said
Bloomberg has been doing really well
Bloomberg has bought his way in he's in
fourth place I told you last week he was
like 1/2 point ahead of Pete Budaj edge
now he's almost a point and a half ahead
of Pete Budaj edge and he is solidly
more solidly in fourth place and as I
said before I believe Bloomberg strategy
of pouring money into Super Tuesday
states is going to end up with him doing
no worse than third I believe that
Elizabeth Warren has lost all momentum
and that it is possible that Michael
Bloomberg ends up with as many or more
delegates than the number Elizabeth
Warren ends up with in third place I
believe by the time it's all said and
done Bloomberg will be no worse than
third place but without being in the
debates it's going to be tougher
so the DNC signaled a couple weeks ago
yeah we might change the rules once
people start voting we knew it would be
possibly to let Michael Bloomberg in and
the way they did it is by saying listen
before any votes are cast we have our
requirements we have a donor requirement
we have a polling requirement once
people start voting people are speaking
we should consider just going by polling
support and result in the prime
Aries and case in point exactly as
predicted after New Hampshire just in
time for Bloomberg to get on to the
debate stage before Nevada and South
Carolina and Super Tuesday the DNC is
going to double the polling requirement
but they are getting rid of the
individual donor requirement altogether
so starting in mid-february
if Michael Bloomberg can keep growing
his support he will be on the debate
stage and hilariously it's conceivable
that Bloomberg will be in and Pete Budaj
edge will not but that's an unlikely
scenario which will see the new
requirements are you need at least 10
percent support in four polls between
January 15 and February 18 or 12% in two
polls in Nevada and South Carolina to be
at the February 19th debate if you earn
at least one delegate in Iowa or New
Hampshire you also can be at that next
debate so look well is that in the next
to it so there's one Friday the one
after that so when you look at these
requirements Bloomberg had 10% in a
recent poll if you go back to January 15
he I think was over 10 in some other
polls it will see if they're allowed in
there's a very specific list of which
polls are allowed so the polling
requirement might or might not qualify
him but his trajectory suggests that
Bloomberg could end up in that end of
February debate as of today only Biden
Bernie and Warren qualified we're still
two weeks out Pete Budaj edge not
qualified as of right now if I'm the
supporter of one of these other
candidates I'm furious when I see this
there is logic to listen people are
voting now so we don't need donor
accounts it makes some sense but the
thing is people aren't really going to
be voting for Bloomberg in these
upcoming primaries Bloomberg is barely
doing anything in Iowa and in New
Hampshire he's skipping right to pouring
money into and resources into the Super
Tuesday States nothing about Bloomberg's
situation really has changed other than
polling support now at the same time as
I said before if you step back and you
look and you see you've got Bernie Biden
and Warren and then you've got Bloomberg
and then behind that is P
Buddha jej who's been in basically every
debate it is weird not to have Bloomberg
at the debates
it when you see the level of support he
has you would say that's someone we
probably should be hearing from but as I
said before these are the rules that the
DNC set now they have the risk of
enraging people if they change the rules
to let Bloomberg in which they are at
least potentially doing we'll see if
Bloomberg ends up getting in let me say
one other thing does it not matter that
much if you're in the debates at this
point I don't know the answer to this
but my point is Pete Budaj edge has been
in every debate and he's lost support
for the last three months
weekly Pete Budaj edges losing support
Bloomberg with door-to-door campaigning
and YouTube and television advertising
has passed Klobuchar has passed Tulsi
has passed Tom Styer has passed Andrew
Yang and most recently has passed Pete
Budaj edge maybe the debates aren't that
important let me know what you think
we're gonna follow up on this on our
Instagram page at David Pakman show
follow me on instagram at david pakman
we will take a quick break coming up
next Kansas City when I say Kansas City
what state do you think of let me talk
about that after the break I know that
the David Pakman show audience is full
of curious and creative people who love
learning new things and bettering
themselves and that's why I'm so excited
to tell you about one of our sponsors
Skillshare the vibrant online learning
community that offers thousands of
classes on almost any topic you can
imagine and you'll get full access to
the entire library of classes for two
entire months free when you go to david
pakman.com slash skill all of the
classes are taught by experts in their
fields they've got classes on drawing
painting photography video editing web
design bookkeeping marketing personal
productivity doesn't even scratch the
surface I recently took a class about
photography if anybody follows me on
Instagram you know that my photography
skills leave much to be desired and it
was great I got so much out of it and
hopefully you will see the fruits of me
taking that class
selected in my Instagram pictures sooner
than later they have classes for every
skill level whether you're wanting to
get better at something you already have
experience with you want to learn
something totally new to you you set
your own pace classes are usually less
than an hour long they're divided up
into bite-size segments so you can
easily fit them into your schedule make
2020 a year where you explore new skills
deep in existing passions get lost in
creativity Skillshare really makes it
easier than ever
Skillshare memberships are less than 10
bucks a month and that gives you access
to the thousands of classes they offer
but everybody in the David Pakman show
audience gets a Skillshare membership
totally free for two whole months just
go to david pakman.com slash skill
that's david pakman.com slash s ki ll